so I'd like to start if I may by asking
you some questions if you've ever lost
someone you truly love ever had your
heart broken ever struggled through an
acrimonious divorce or being the victim
of infidelity please stand up if
standing up isn't accessible to you you
can put your hand up please
stay standing and keep your hand up
there if you've ever lived through a
natural disaster being bullied or be
made redundant stand on up if you've
ever had a miscarriage if you've ever
had an abortion or struggled through
infertility please stand up finally if
you or anyone you love has had to cope
with mental illness dementia some form
of physical impairments or cope with
suicide please stand up look around you
adversity doesn't discriminate if you
are alive you are going to have to or
you've already had to deal with some
tough times
thank you everyone take a seat I started
studying resilience research a decade
ago at the University of Pennsylvania in
Philadelphia it was an amazing time to
be there because the professors who
trained me had just picked up the
contract to train all 1.1 million
American soldiers to be as mentally fit
as they always have been physically fit
as you can imagine you don't get a much
more skeptical discerning audience than
the American drill sergeants returning
from Afghanistan so for someone like me
whose main quest in life is trying to
work out how we take the best of
scientific findings out of academia and
bring them to people in their everyday
lives it was a pretty inspiring place to
be I finished my studies in Amer
and I returned home here to Christchurch
to start my doctoral research I just
begun that study when the Christchurch
earthquakes hit so I put my research on
holes and I started working with my home
community to help them through that
terrible post-quake period I work with
all sorts of organizations from
government departments to building
companies and all sorts of community
groups teaching them the ways of
thinking and acting that we know boost
resilience I thought that was my calling
my moment to put all of that research to
good use but sadly I was wrong for my
own true test came in 2014 on queen's
birthday weekend we and two other
families had decided to go down to lake
ohel and bike the outs to ocean at the
last minute my beautiful twelve-year-old
daughter Abby decided to hop in the car
with her best friend Ella also 12 and
Ella's mom Sally a dear dear friend of
mine on the way down as they traveled
through rakaia on Thompson's track a car
sped through a stop sign crashing into
them and killing all three of them
instantly in the blink of an eye I find
myself flung to the other side of the
equation waking up with a whole new
identity instead of being the resilience
expert suddenly I'm the grieving mother
waking up not knowing who I am trying to
wrap my head around unthinkable news my
world smashed to smithereens suddenly
I'm the one on the end of all this
expert advice and I can tell you I
didn't like what I heard one little bit
in the days after Abby died we were told
we were now prime candidates for family
estrangement that we were likely to get
divorced
and we were a high risk of mental
illness Wow I remember thinking thanks
for that I thought my life was a really
pretty [ __ ] leaflets described the five
stages of brief anger bargaining denial
depression acceptance victim support
arrived at our door and told us that we
could expect to write off the next five
years to grief I know the leaflets and
the resources meant well but in all of
that advice they left us feeling like
victims totally overwhelmed by the
journey ahead and powerless to exert any
influence over our grieving whatsoever I
didn't need to be told how bad things
were believe me I already knew things
were truly terrible what I needed most
was hope I needed a journey through all
that anguish pain and longing most of
all I wanted to be an active participant
in my grief process so I decided to turn
my back on their advice and decided
instead to conduct something of a self
experiment I'd done the research I had
the tools I wanted to know how useful
they would be to me now in the face of
such an enormous mountain to climb now I
have to confess at this point one didn't
really know that any of this was going
to work
parental bereavement is widely
acknowledged as the hardest of losses to
bear but I can tell you now five years
on what I already knew from the research
that you can rise up from adversity that
there are strategies that work that it
is utterly possible to make yourself
think and act in certain ways that help
you navigate tough times there is a
monumental body of research on how to do
this stuff today I'm just going to share
with you three strategies
these are my go-to strategies that I
relied upon and saved me in my darkest
days there are three strategies that
underpin all of my work and they're
pretty readily available to us all
anyone can learn them you can learn them
right here today so number one resilient
people get that [ __ ] happens they know
that suffering is part of life
this doesn't mean they actually welcome
it in they're not actually delusional
just that when the tough times come they
seem to know that suffering is part of
every human existence and knowing this
stops you from feeling discriminated
against when the tough times come never
once did I find myself thinking why me
in fact I remember thinking why not me
terrible things happen to you just like
they do everybody else that's your life
now time to sink or swim the real
tragedy is that not enough of us seem to
know this any longer we seem to live in
an age where we're entitled to a perfect
life we're shiny happy photos on
Instagram are the norm when actually as
you all demonstrated at the start of my
talk the very opposite is true
number two resilient people are really
good at choosing carefully where they
select their attention they have a habit
of realistically appraising situations
and typically managing to focus on the
things that they can change and somehow
accept the things that they can't this
is a vital learn herbal skill for
resilience as humans we are really good
at noticing threats and weaknesses we
are hardwired for that negative we
really really
good at noticing them negative emotions
stick to us like velcro whereas positive
emotions and experiences seem to bounce
off like Teflon being wired in this way
is actually really good for us and
served us well from an evolutionary
perspective so imagine for a moment I'm
a cave woman and I'm coming out of a
cave in the morning and there's a
saber-toothed tiger on one side and a
beautiful rainbow on the other it kind
of pays for my survival for me to notice
this tiger the problem is we now live in
an era where we are constantly bombarded
by threats all day long and our poor
brains treat every single one of those
threats as though they were a tiger our
threat focus our stress response is
permanently dialed up resilient people
don't diminish the negative but they
also have worked out a way of tuning in
to the good one day when doubts were
threatening to overwhelm me I distinctly
remember thinking no you do not get to
get swallowed up by this you have to
survive you've got so much to live for
choose life not death don't lose what
you have to what you have lost in
psychology we call this benefit finding
in my brave new world it involved trying
to find things to be grateful for at
least our week girl hadn't died of some
terrible long drawn-out illness she died
suddenly instantly sparing us and her
that pain we had a huge amount of social
support from family and friends to help
us through and most of all we still had
two beautiful boys to live for who
needed us now and deserve to have as
normal a life as we could possibly give
them being able to switch the focus of
your attention to also include
the good has been shown by science to be
a really powerful strategy so in 2005
Marty Seligman and collies conducted an
experiment and they asked people all
they asked people to do was think of
three good things that had happened to
them each day what they found over the
six months course of this study was that
those people showed higher levels of
gratitude higher levels of happiness and
less depression over the course of the
six months study when you're going
through grief you might need a reminder
or you might need permission to feel
grateful in our kitchen we've got a
bright pink neon poster that reminds us
to accept the good in the American army
they framed it a little bit differently
they talked to the army about hunting
the good stuff find the language that
works for you but whatever you do make
an intentional deliberate ongoing effort
to tune in to what's good in your world
number three resilient people ask
themselves is what I'm doing helping or
harming me this is a question that's
used a lot in good therapy and boy is it
powerful this was my go-to question in
the days after the girls died I would
ask it again and again should I go to
the trial and see the driver would that
help me or would it harm me well that
was a no-brainer for me I chose to stay
away but Trevor my husband decided to
meet with the driver at a later time
late at night I'd find myself sometimes
pouring over old photos of a be getting
more and more upset I'd ask myself
really is this helping you or is it
harming you put away the photos go to
bed for the night be kind to yourself
this question can be applied to so many
different context is the way I'm
thinking and acting helping or harming
you in your beat
to get that promotion to pass that exam
to recover from a heart attack so many
different ways I write a lot about
resilience and over the years this one
strategy has prompted more positive
feedback than any other I get scores of
letters and emails and things from all
over the place for people saying what a
huge impact it's had on their lives
whether it is forgiving family ancient
transgressions arguments from
Christmases past or whether it is just
trolling through social media whether it
is asking yourself whether you really
need that extra glass of wine asking
yourself whether what you're doing the
way you're thinking the way you're
acting is helping or harming you puts
you back in the driver's seat it gives
you some control over your
decision-making three strategies pretty
simple they're readily available to us
all Anytime Anywhere they don't require
rocket science resilience isn't some
fixed trait it's not illusive that some
people have and some people don't
it's actually requires very ordinary
processes just the willingness to give
them a go I think we all have moments in
life where our life path splits and the
journey we thought we were going down
takes some terrible veers off to some
terrible direction that we never
anticipated and we certainly didn't want
it happened to me it was awful beyond
imagining if you ever find yourself in a
situation where you think there's no way
I'm coming back from this I urge you to
lean into these strategies and think
again I won't pretend that thinking this
way is easy and it doesn't remove or
the pain but if I've learned anything
over the last five years it is that
thinking this way really does help more
than anything it has shown me that it is
possible to live and grieve at the same
time and for that I will be always
grateful thank you
[Applause]